today
歩きたい
自分の
足デー
私は今でも
そう
思っています
段差
階段
坂道
町には
不便がいい
生活には
不自由がいい
私だけではありません
障害のある方
ご高齢の方
ベビーカーを押すかだ
合わせたら日本で暮らす人の3割を超えます
その人たちには
共に行動する
家族や友人もいます
多くの人が感じる
不便や不安を解消するため
私は考えました
多様な方がゆったりくつろげる良寛
家族みんなで幸せを共有する
結婚式場
それぞれの可能性を広げる
スポーツ人
ありとあらゆる場所を生きやすく
過ごしやすくしています
お墓も
その一つです
かつてレーンは砂利道や狭い道で
多くの人が移動しづらい場所でさ
そこで
これまでにない
バリアフリーの霊園を
実現しました
目が見えない人も皆と同じようにアートを楽しみたい
名画を触って分かるようにしました
ありとあらゆる人が楽しめる空間を実現しました
行きたい場所へ行けるかどうか
いきやすい道順はどれか
一目でわかる地図を作りましたん
今ではスマートフォンさえあればどこにいても見ることができます
これらは
社会貢献のみならず
ビジネスで
大きな市場がチャンスがあります
多くの人が求めていることだからこそ
続けていかなければいけません
広げていかなければいけません
社会性と
経済性
料理んあってこその継続です
世界には
10億人の障害者が暮らしています
そして
どの国でも
高齢化は進みます
取り組むべきは
日本だけではありません
10年前
私は
良質に言いました
歩くことを夢見亭
手術を受け
毎日
リハビリに
明け暮れました
しかし
歩くことは
叶いませんでした
夢断たれた日
私は自ら
命午後
立とうとしました
でも
私の足では
飛び降りることも
できませんでした
死ぬことすらできない自分に
絶望しました
病室のベッドの上で
枕に顔を押し付け
散々泣きました
けれど
人並みだわ
中間も持ちません
泣き明かした後
考えました
ここまでやってダメなら仕方がない
そう思えるまでとことん向き合おうと
可能性がないと
分かっていながらも
歩くための努力を
続けました
全力で
結果
やっぱり
ダメでした
今日も私は車椅子に乗っています
幼少期からずっと抱いた歩きたいという思いはこれから先も
消えることはないでしょう
それでも
最後の
リハビリを終えたとき
私の心は晴れ晴れとしていたことを
覚えています
私は
歩けなくても出来ることを探し始めました
良質を出て猛勉強の末に大学へ入学しました
学費を賄うため私はアルバイトをする必要がありました
コンビニファミレス新聞配達
車椅子の私にできることはありません
履歴書を持って多くの会社を回ったところ
1社だけ私を拾ってくれました
web 制作の
会社でした
すっかりデザインの仕事をするものと思っていたところ
出社初日私が任せられたのは
営業の仕事でした
他の営業は1日100件近く回ってきます
一方私はせいぜい10件程度で示唆
駅にエレベーターがない建物に段差がある
お伺いすることさえかなわないしもありました
なんとか
諦めずに
続けていると
また車いすの営業が来た
また垣内が来てるぞと
覚えてもらい気づけば
その会社で一番の売り上げ
結果を残していました
歩けなくてもできること
だけではない
歩けないから
障害があるから
できることもあいっ
私は
新たな道に
たどり着きました
振り返れば
苦しいこと
辛い事ばかりでした
しかし
不幸ではありません
歩けなかったからこそ
得られたチャンスがありました
出会えた人がいました
バリア
バリ
障害は危険を変えれば勝ちに変われ
私はそう
信じています
障害だけではありません例えば仕事が遅いとしましょう
でもそれは人より丁寧な仕事をしているのかもしれません
落ち着けにかけるのは目先のことだけではなく広い視野を持って行動しているのかも
しれません
不安になりやすいのは
人一倍責任感が強く
最善の準備をしているのかも
しれません
誰もが持っている
弱みや
コンプレックスは
強み
勝ちに変わる瞬間があります
もちろん
すぐには
難しいでしょう
でも
向き合い続けることで信じることで
バリアは
バリューに変わります
二十歳の時
私は会社を立ち上げました
障害者の下に経験感性を生かす会社です
今多くの仲間と
バリアを
バリ上
変えています
ここで
私の人生を変えてくれた1人の女性との話をしましょう
私は
田んぼと山ばかりの町で育ちました
1たり外へ出れば山あり谷あり
車椅子では移動が大変でした
家から学校まで
友人がいつも車いすを押してくれました
でも私には
車いすを
をしてもらいたくない
をしてもらえない
高校生の頃
お付き合いしていた
恋人です
小さな
プライドでした
車移送をしてもらうことが
情けない
恥ずかしい
かっこ悪い
そんな風に
思っていました
ある日
可能者が私に言いまし
手をつないで歩きたいと
車いすに乗っている私と手をつなげば目立ちます
私はすぐに断りました
彼女に
冷たい視線を
浴びせたくなかったからです
ところが彼女はこう続けました
付き合ってるんだから
手をつなぐのは当然でしょと
それから私は片手で車いすをこぐ練習をして
彼女とはどこへ行くにも
手をつなぐ
なりました
私と歩く彼女は
恥ずかしがるどころか
いつも
笑顔でした
しばらくして
彼女が手をつなごうといった
もう一つの理由を
知りました
手をつないで
坂道を
歩いていると
私のほうが遅くなり
自然と彼女に引っ張られる格好になります
坂道に差し掛かった時私は彼女へ負担をかけないように
ここからは自分で漕ぐよと伝えてを離そうとしました
すると彼女は手を離すことなく笑って私に言いました
車椅子を押すなとは言われたけど
引っ張るなとは言われてないよと
ありがとう
その言葉が出るより先に
涙が出ました
家から
一歩外へれれば私は周囲の人に手伝ってもらってばかり
口を開けば
すみませんすみませんと言い続け
下ばかり見ていました
でもこの時は違いました
顔を上げて前を見ました
その先に
私の気を引いてくれる
笑顔の彼女が
いたからです
すみませんと
いい続けた人生から
ありがとう等
伝え続ける
人生
変わりました
彼女が
彼女なりに考えた
その答えに
私は
救われました
車椅子だからをしてあげよう
手伝ってあげようではない
目の前の人と
どのように向き合うか
どのように共に歩むか
今はそれをユニバーサルマナーと名付け
私が伝え続けています
これから皆さんも学校や職場
街中で多様な形と向き合うことになるでしょう
どんな建物が快適なのか
どんな
製品が
買いやすいのか
どんな手助けが喜ばれるのか
正解はありません
皆さんの考える
それぞれの答えが
誰かの救いに
つながるはずです
ハードも
ハートも
世界に誇れる日本を
誰もが
バリアを
バリューとできる未来を
皆さんとともに
実現できたらと
願っています
[拍手]